yeah can I ask you a question though or
ask the group a question there's more
world leaders who are male and typically
I think that's a good thing women should
not impede positions of extreme
leadership like presidents Etc et cetera
because we're too emotional I'm feeling
a lot of emotion right now
[Music]
if you agree step forward women have
more privileges today than men
I went back and forth on this one
thinking about the difference between
more and different I think women have
distinctly different privileges than men
have but with this new feminist movement
that is arising more of the third fourth
wave we are finding I think that women
are
placed and pedestalized above men in a
lot of ways there's affirmative action
hiring and scholarships where women
sometimes even regardless of academic
standing or achievement are prioritized
above men but men also have different
privileges that they get to access I
struggle to say more but I think I do
agree with the feminist movement now
there is more if you are born into this
life with a vagina you inherently have
10 times more privilege than a man from
the time they are little girls are
always like doted on and you're so
pretty and cute very coddled they're
cuddle right as they should be you know
they're we want that feminine nurturing
energy in them you can kind of be a
degenerate woman and have a hot body and
be a Millionaire on only fans men don't
have that privilege now women don't have
to like work to get a guy they're just
hot and then they get guys come to them
and spend their resources on them a man
has to prove himself he has to build a
body he has to make money he has to
build build influence he has to become a
protector a provider women just have
that naturally by just having a vagina
that's why it's frustrating because the
feminist movement has been all about
women acting like they don't have rights
and acting like they have it pretty hard
in the modern day world I can't think of
a single thing that I don't have that a
guy has or that they only I would say
the one thing I would say is the safety
thing that's the only thing that I would
say is that women are disadvantaged from
by Nature women are not as physically
strong I mean you're physically strong
but as physically strong
and men just are and if you're walking
down a dark alley as a woman you're
you're going to feel some type of way
sometimes right we need guns well there
you go I'm going to talk a little bit
more about like the judicial system when
it comes to let's say domestic dispute
if a woman calls the police they
automatically show up arrest the man
this the Duluth model I think is how you
pronounce it and that's already in place
it's not necessarily like a right or
anything but it's certainly in all of
the police departments is that feminism
is all about equality why would you
automatically arrest a man when they
arrest him his name is in the newspaper
automatically the fact that a woman can
say Jane Doe and she doesn't have to put
her name out there what skin in the game
is there and there's so many instances
of that I know men personally who have
had domestic violence within their
relationship with children involved
unfortunately and the you know the woman
attacked the man in front of the child
and he's still I know two instances
personally and he's still fighting to
get the child back that's from the metoo
movement congratulations you guys got
that it kind of invalidates the women
who do come forward and who have faced
rape and sexual assault and all of that
because then it kind of turned into a
Twitter hashtag that's correct where
women were like oh you know what I want
to join like the same is fun like for
classes I think it's a mixed bag I don't
think the metoo movement wasn't
inherently harmful it's the metoo
movement when you couple it with
something like believe all women that's
when it becomes uh and the victimization
of women who aren't really victims the
promptest do women have more privileges
we have privileges simply by virtue of
being women we have privileges with
affirmative action we have privileges in
family court and we have privileges as
far as being believed and forgiven it's
a it's something that should be
acknowledged that's correct gonna have
the disagree step forward
I appreciated the distinction of more
versus different privileges you can't
just use a broad brush and and paint the
entire debate and say all right well
this is men have more than women that's
it like women that must inherently then
have no privileges that's that's not how
it works and that's where we start to
get into the idea of like
intersectionality where another woman
who had a different experience if it was
a trans woman if it was a woman of color
if it was a woman who was including
trans women into feminism and I think we
definitely should I don't think we
should at all I think that trans women
should not be a part of the feminist
movement because a man just because they
you know wake up and feel like they can
be a woman one day could come in and
then suddenly know what it's like to
have a period or know what it's like to
have a child it's anything from men
replacing women in sports to men
replacing women on podcasts during
women's month and when we're talking
about women's health or you've even got
biological men who think they're women
going to the White House speaking on
behalf of all women I do have a question
for you based on the prompt though
because you've lived in both experiences
at least socially I'm curious when you
transition to male and people started
perceiving you as male like most people
did today what privileges change for you
or what did you see enter your life that
you didn't have before yeah and that's
that's sort of where a lot of my my
beliefs in feminism do lie is because
being out into the world as a gay woman
was the way I was seen men treated me
definitely not nearly as well as they
did I was bullied in school I had people
call me slurs and it seemed like it was
because I was threatening to like the
male structure that we are in where it's
like male and female because I was a
female who liked females I was somehow
infringing on that and so they didn't
like me things change naturally when you
socially transition and are perceived by
the world in a different way when I
transitioned from being perceived as
female to the world to just pretty much
passing or blending full-time as male
was that I got a lot more respect from
other other men people listened to me
and took me seriously in a social
passing setting
um people aren't going to harass women
who are around me if I'm walking with
them at night which is just a benefit I
never thought about with caveat
um actually so I say that yes there are
some privileges that women have that men
don't but also there's privileges that
men have that women do I don't think
women are more privileged on our society
because I can get a woman pregnant and I
could just run away they could get you
well thank you
at the end of the day like I don't see
women having more privileges than men
because we don't have the same if
there's no way to objectively measure it
well and then the scenario that you
pointed out I mean if a woman was
pregnant she wouldn't be able to get an
abortion and in some states yes yeah
that's a major disadvantage yeah you
can't get an abortion but children can
go get a gender change at 12 years
you're very fixated without consent
that's not true
I I know the laws as well I went through
this I know in some states you can and
in Thailand you can go at 16 and get
your everything cut off guys it's less
than less than five percent it's such a
small subset but you can't say that
about it does matter that when you have
a child you're not that's between the
parent and the child can I ask you a
question though or ask the group a
question there's more world leaders who
are male and typically I think that's a
good thing I know it's coming from me
but I do want to know it doesn't bum you
out that it's less likely for a woman to
become president I don't feel bummed out
because I know that if I want to pursue
something that I want to do I have every
capability to do it in this country I
don't feel bummed out women should not
impede positions of extreme leadership
like presidents Etc et cetera because
we're too emotional
wait one person so she can hear it to be
logical and to be sound is not something
defined by gender it's just something
defined by your own side the left and
right brain it actually is though
your question about leadership I think
is a very poignant question because a
lot of people are asking that why don't
we see more female presidents why don't
we see more female CEOs or Fortune 500
companies and again it goes back to
those gender differences there will be
women who will be exceptions to the
generalized rule of what it means to be
feminine and those women you will see
succeed in extreme leadership but we
should also discuss what the conditions
of extreme leadership are we're talking
80-hour work weeks subscribing yourself
to your career and nothing else children
psychologically and biologically women
tend to lean in the direction of not
making those choices for themselves
while men are highly competitive they
are highly analytical systematic they're
willing to put in that time and take
Extreme Measures to gain career status
exactly in a regulatory Society is about
having that choice to make that decision
yes but we do but we already have that
choice if I want to go own my own
company like I said in the beginning
we've all agreed that the beginning of
feminism was going in the wrong American
women it was humanizing women it was
making them equal to men it was giving
us the same opportunities so that we can
go vote so that I can go get a job so
that I can drive a car like other
country wants that I know that we
weren't talking about other countries
but if you want to talk about feminism
go protect the women who get beat up for
driving a car in other countries
men are falling behind in society
I just think I mean we have amazing men
here today
with you to see this masculine energy
however I know that men are not able to
be men anymore because of the feminists
modern feminists propaganda I coach men
in my practice and they tell me like I
don't even know if I what I can do on a
date anymore can I ask a woman out am I
going to get in trouble for this now
like I really like her I kind of want to
put my hand around her waist but maybe
that's gonna you know I'm gonna be all
over social media this kind of thing and
I think men don't have the balls anymore
to just stand up and be a man be
dangerous
be fierce I want to respond to him he
said please does anybody else um you
make a really interesting point however
I feel like a lot of the reasons why men
can't actively Express masculinity in a
positive way is because of the
patriarchal structures that we have part
of where I'm coming from with this is
I'm trans so I was born female now I
present as male I came out socially and
medically transitioned at 18. okay the
feminist movement is what helped me feel
empowered enough
to be who I am and be a man no
disrespect to your process I know it's a
very strenuous thing that you go through
but I see a woman still I feel feminine
energy from you that's all right so when
you say you're a man then it's like
I don't see that the way I think about
it is more like about individual choice
and individual freedom and if I want to
say that I have feminine energy and
people view me as masculine or vice
versa then that's their problem that's
not my problem and for me that's what
um feminism is about is about giving
people the choice to act in accordance
with however the hell they want to but
that's a very dangerous Society that's
not how feminism started though yeah we
went from you know wanting equal rights
for women and equality for women and now
it's humanizing women humanizing women
making it to where I think we all agree
you know women now are equal to men and
with like third and fourth wave feminism
especially Fourth Way feminism it's kind
of turned into individuality like you
said it doesn't take a man to tell me
how to be a man it doesn't take a woman
either I I can Define myself as a man
how I want to
um I don't need somebody like Andrew
Tate to be like you're not a man unless
you do this I also don't need a woman to
come up and like you're not a real man
if you don't do this and it's the same
with femininity I'm not going to tell
you how to be a woman I don't think
another woman should tell you how to be
a woman either so what would you tell
kids yeah like he has this he you have a
daughter do you really want to be guided
by the ambiguous Define yourself as
however you want to Define yourself and
for her mind to be molded and shaped by
men who no disrespect women who turn
themselves into men and then turn
themselves back and say there's a lot of
dissatisfaction when the root of the
problem wasn't the gender it was
everything else exactly slow down there
I feel like yeah
it's also a minority feels like you're
bundling a lot of ideas which makes it
hard to respond but is there so much
data to support you repeat that what's
the main question do you want your
daughter's mind
shaped by a society that that tells her
it's okay to be masculine and to be a
man and that she doesn't need a man and
that it's better off for her to be alone
and put her career first and not have
children I think it's more likely than
not that she'll probably follow a more
conventional path if my daughter grows
up and she wants to dress like a boy
like great if she
for whatever reason is experiencing
gender dysphoria like we would navigate
that together but that to me it doesn't
because my son I encourage him I say you
are to be and I really don't care the
backlash you're supposed to be attracted
to women
no and I and I ask him what if he's not
because life for transgender individuals
and my son's African-American as well is
very freaking hard I don't know if we
can swear I'm sorry you can it's very
hard do you know this to be true asking
people or putting pressure on your son
or putting pressure on my daughter to
not just tell him okay but to not be
their true self if that's truly how they
feel it feels like that one is this like
thank you that's this way Society has
influenced everybody
I can be whatever I want if I want to
say I'm Beyonce today I can now just be
be honest but do you actually believe
that absolutely yeah
Farm behind is it because of feminism or
is there socioeconomic factors that
we're not looking at well how do we
because well no no no no what do you see
is falling it's falling behind so people
in America not just men everybody is
getting poor this is nothing to do
that's a mental statement
whatever you wanted to be it doesn't
have to be this objective thing where
it's like oh you're a mask when you're
not like so it could be different from
our society to another society and
actually in some countries like men who
don't provide for their families or not
Sole Provider or not but are we talking
about other countries
actually even here there are people who
will say that's demasculating for a man
to make less money than his wife I
appreciate everything everyone's saying
I I do want to talk about the prompt
when I heard the prompt and I heard that
you know I thought about men falling
behind I thought more like mental health
like suicide is more common we're going
to go here no but it's true like men
like I'm not saying mental health is an
issue that it is an issue and obviously
a lot of men are having experiencing a
lot of pressure have you heard like the
term death of Despair men are committing
suicide more men are dying from alcohol
related illness is more and they're also
dying from drug abuse and drug overdose
more correct and that that's an
increasing Trend in society and then you
see an educational gaps no there is no
denying that like young men are
abandoning colleges at a rapid rapid
it's a lot of pressure to be a man
they're always far earlier than women
are you know yeah
can I finish my point Sorry Sorry I'm
like don't let me lose my train of
thought they're abandoning colleges
women make up they enroll in college at
a 60 rate women are earning more than
men nowadays right so
um
it's about enrollment so are they having
other jobs yeah probably but I'm saying
like men are not going to these
institutions why when you're seeing lack
of enrollment there's more
entrepreneurials in the entrepreneurial
space than ever before in history so I
believe a lot of people are opting out
of college as we had to pursue their
Venture so that could be part of the
reason why the enrollment has declined I
just go back to a point that you said
really quick where you talked about like
the mental health of men and how like
yeah the stigmatization of men
addressing their mental health yeah what
system are we in that makes it so that
men have this big stigma around our
mental health where we can't talk about
it and the suicide rate goes on so we
are in a patriarchal system
those are the balance we are within
correct there's a lot that's toxic
Mexican
complete his point I'll encourage you to
let the other person finish the point
and then of course you can take it
forward but let them talk I'm just real
quick systemic structures we are in are
patriarchy that is what has caused men
to have this massive stigma amount
around mental health where we don't feel
empowered to reach out men tend to not
go to therapy that leads to Suicide that
leads to all of these big things that's
not caused by feminism that was
happening well before the feminist
movement came into these memories
there's a lot of
psychiatrists psychologists and
economists professors all these people
coming out saying that the actual
psychology department is feminized I
know I know what you're saying but the
way that it everything's processed is
for women so women and men process
information differently men are like
this in their brain women are it's all
over and like what the hell does that
means
process like men need to solve the
problem correct before they can process
the emotion women
yeah that's it but so women have a
tendency not a tendency they do better
with talk therapy that doesn't always
work for a man men men do better when
they are kind of working with a coach or
somebody that's going to be like this is
what you have to do and then come back
that's why mentors work that's why men
need to see how I thought though can we
let him finish his thoughts okay the
same problems with the military a lot of
the suicide right um even though there
is Therapy Services they're actually
actively discouraged and it's because of
this masculine energy in the military
because it is still even to this day a
very Ultra masculine institution and
there's these negative energies saying
like hey no you shouldn't like a talk
that's what these [__] do but that's
right yes
no it comes from a place where it's like
oh that's not what men do just suck it
up and push on and that's why a lot of
these guys end up killing themselves but
what what branch were you in can I ask I
was in the Army so you're an athlete
correct and in the military what is in
the military that makes everything work
within the military it's a structure
right yes it's a structure it's a system
right who runs the military who is at
the very top of the command oh the
commander-in-chief the president of the
United States but I'm making a point
here so there's one person at the very
top even if you take the
commander-in-chief away there's your
general right then there's Lieutenant
General there's Corporal and I forget
that don't hate me there's all those
privates Etc there's a system one person
is at the top of that system and he has
supporting members underneath him all
the way down to private and that's what
patriarchy was quote patriarcher was
designed it's a system of one person
taking a leadership position and they
make decisions for the greater good
utilitarianism of all meaning the family
unit right that's not really what the
Patriot and actually it is I looked up
the definition there's actually a very I
literally looked it up yesterday
the male feminist also to respond
because I feel like they've spoken 20
percent once they're done with their
thought feel free to interrupt but let
them finish the sentence okay I want to
talk
I'm gonna talk I mean I do think men are
falling behind I feel like the world is
just changing in a way where men don't
have like a natural place to fit in
um or it's not as as intuitive as it
used to be and I think men are alone I
heard you throughout the word loneliness
and that does feel true I just don't
think that feminism did that I just
think like the world is changing what
you said really resonated with me when
we Define falling behind what I think
about with men is that high suicide rate
that likeliness uh and proclivity
towards violence and aggression I think
about loneliness and not being in
relationships with young which young men
are struggling with a lot right now and
where I feel finding common ground and
feminism does get right in a sense is
that we should expand our Horizons as
far as how we view masculinity men
should be able to cry they should be
able to be vulnerable and that's
something that we need to access but
also these men who are feeling
disillusioned with the world right now
they are seeking out male figures we've
seen you know the rise of the Jordan
Petersons or some of the personalities
that the daily wire or the Andrew Tates
they are seek out somebody who's telling
them I want you to access those
masculine traits and harness them in a
way I would say Jordan Peterson's
probably a more healthy role model for
men than saying Andrew Tate but men are
going towards these more aggressive
masculinized traits and seeking out men
that are trying to harness that for them
yeah I just I thought you made a really
great point that I totally agree with
where men are looking for these role
models of how to embody masculinity
because we are falling behind and a lot
of people don't know how to act what's
really important and what I've seen at
least in my experience like feminism
bring up is the idea of um like Justin
baldoni doing his talk about being man
enough for your woman being man enough
to be emotional being man enough to
support children that's the type of
Manliness and masculinity I think needs
to be embodied so that men can catch up
and feel like there's a place for them
that's something that we need to focus
on is making sure that people know how
to body masculinity in a way that's
going to be beneficial for everyone
women should also be drafted into the
military
[Music]
foreign
if you're going to vote you might as
well be drafted baby that's it yeah I
believe rights come with
responsibilities and we are all
responsible individuals granted I'm glad
we live in a society where we haven't
had the draft since I think this Vietnam
Vietnam I think Vietnam I I do think
that maybe like we should re-look at the
draft and as other options not just
military service so I I was in active
duty military and I was also in the
National Guard and I've I've fought
wildfires and like uh I've done crowd
control I've done a lot of other things
if you want the same rights you have to
have the same responsibilities and I
think that's just Universal based on
what you can do and your abilities this
was a very difficult one for me to parse
through because I I remember when I was
getting my birth certificate changed and
it was like all right time to register
for Selective Service and I was like oh
God I have to make this decision now
um to register you don't have a choice I
know I know so I was like all right cool
um like I will go through with finishing
all this all this legal stuff up and
register and I think like you said
there's lots of other responsibilities
that men and women of different
abilities and different different
strengths could fulfill within selective
service if we needed it
drafted correct me if I'm wrong would be
going into war would be physically going
and doing not just the actual a lot of
the draftees in Vietnam didn't go see
combat they did supportive rules okay
it's selective service so you register
to be potentially needed to call for
multiple different responses right but
some of them are going right right so
there was some so bad cases the part
that I would disagree with would be
putting women on the front lines we are
physically capable to do a lot you know
there's different boundaries for women
who go into the military who have to do
boot camp than there are for men we can
work women as hard as they can but
they're not going to work as hard as men
are I actually got accepted into the air
force which would have been like very
nice because I would had a little desk
job but unfortunately I was waiting for
a job so I went to Army so I went
through boot camp and it was hell and it
really messed my back up even more than
it already was our rationale skills and
our logical thinking is not conducive to
be able to be on the front grounds to be
able to make oh my gosh if I step here
this is going to blow up can I like we
just think too emotionally and that's
why when we talked about leadership it's
the same thing being in those positions
where like Split Second decision could
make or break I don't think women have
it in them to do that and I don't think
it's fair to men to be I wouldn't if I
was a man I wouldn't want to be next to
a woman and want to be carried out if I
needed to be if my life was depending on
it I think it seems like a lot of the
same discussions keep happening with
these prompts which is a back and forth
of how much is it nature how much does
it nurture how much are there like
intrinsic biological differences between
men and women and how much does that
dictate our behavior and our physiology
our biology versus how much of that is
through social learning so how much are
it's our culture in terms of let's say
like programming on a scale of one to
ten how how high is your sex drive very
high I'm a sexist I'm not asking sorry
if you ask everyone that yeah um you'll
see on average differences between men
and women and because of that I don't
think we should dictate whether or not
someone is drafted into the military
because ultimately I think individuals
should have the freedom
to make certain choices it's a draft
yeah
and you're saying you don't
treat it differently because there can
be metrics that fall outside of the data
of course yeah so there is differential
treatment but I would say that it's
completely reasonable to do that because
not only are we focusing on the
differential treatment but we're
focusing on outcome so if I'm expecting
somebody to go into combat which is the
reason I didn't walk forward you should
also expect that person on an individual
basis to be able to meet the exact same
standard as every other man that they
are going to be fighting with so the
military has made a change on that by
the way they have a new individual test
that's based on what jobs you can do if
you're doing more combat rules yes you
have to be strong and tougher and there
are women Meeting those standards that's
why things are changing and like I said
I'm not for the draft at all really I
think it's a really bad thing but if it
was to happen like it should be across
all boards and be a treated Eagle if I
could choose
the possibility of women being drafted
or not I would choose that they're not
well I don't want my daughter to be
drafted I think if you draft at least
account for the differences please
female sex workers should be more
respected
I don't know a ton about this topic but
I I do think
I I subscribed to the idea that
legitimizing sex work reduces the the
safety risks associated with that
profession it's it's very old profession
it's been around for a while it's going
to continue to be around yeah I don't
you know I think it's it's also there's
tools out there like only fans that I
think has put a lot of the power in the
hands of the creators a lot of people
don't realize like nobody like actively
chooses to be in sex work you're usually
going to sex work because of social
situations and if it's a black market
most people ask why I joined the
military It's like because I was poor
like there was no other [__] reason
and I'm not saying it would get rid of
exploitation but if women have legal
Productions like if I was a prostitute I
could go up to a cop and say hey I got
beat up with my money so I'm not being
worried about being arrested like I
would be more likely to report crimes
and get the people who are causing
problems yeah and then for the people
who just want to do it and want to just
like own their sexuality own their body
and use it as a commodity a way to make
money they should be able to do that in
a way that is safe in a way that they
own all of the videos all of the content
that they make and in a way that is
Equitable for them when it comes to
respect there's two definitions respect
either can mean like politeness like you
wouldn't shut the door on somebody
that's like walking behind you like be
respectful the other respect is usually
if you do something that um in the
workplace that Garner's approval you've
completed a goal so when we talk about
respect when it comes to sex workers
should we be polite to them probably
that would be a human thing to do I
don't have to but yeah I prefer only
fans over the traditional porn issue
because you own you own it and then it's
it's women got sex trafficking but that
agency is important I know that it's
what you own and to have you know that
respect put onto you that like this is
your content you're putting out into the
world yeah now it's their copyrighted
material before when it was the old porn
industry they didn't have rights to
those videos and that's a huge thing
like if I want to take my stuff down you
have to go to a court as a with a
copyright case and it just that's what
happens Mia Khalifa that was her whole
thing and luckily now she's a very
successful career doing like sports
commentating and stuff but that's
unfortunately that's not the rule that's
the exception whether it's a role model
right off the bat you said Mia Khalifa
went from being a porn star to being a
sports commentator
that is something that we should be
directing women towards it shouldn't be
okay well you know she's gonna go doing
only fans or she's going to be in 50
porn videos to get paid when we're
encouraging women to go out of their way
to sell their bodies on the internet
because that's a means to an end we're
not doing that the right way and I don't
think the feminist movement should be
moving in the direction of normalizing
sex work when we should be encouraging
women to Value themselves value their
body value their talent and take that
elsewhere there's a lot of things in
place though for women like yeah there's
obviously a need if they're in maybe a
lower economic class or something but at
the end of the day that's more of like a
morality topic you know and so you can't
really force that on everybody I agree
with you right the other thing would be
is that women are not happy when they're
doing this it's not empowering as a
woman you can go on Twitter and see
these women who are in their 30s with
and only fans Link in their bio with but
with no kids no husband no specific
thing to actually care about it's all
about materialistic things these are the
same women that you're seeing tweeting
about how sad they are they're tweeting
it's not generalized it's the majority
of those women they are on
antidepressants I'd like to speak
because I've actually been in the
industry so I was trafficked for a
decade you hit the no that's okay you
hit the nail on the head I came from a
very poor socio-economic background I
was a product of the state and so I
speak from experience when I say it's
not empowering it's not glorifying it's
not owning your body none of that stuff
is true no little girl when they're four
or five says I want to grow up and be a
hooker only fans is the biggest pimp of
them all they're still taking 20 and
your content still gets leaked a lot I
agree I'm not in favor of any kind of
exploitation I I also am uncomfortable
by the idea of like women I know if they
were in that industry like I admit like
it makes me feel uncomfortable my gut is
so you have a daughter I'm going to be
having a daughter in four months
it's a good question because you're
you're raising a human being for the
future of society that we're going to
all shape how does it make you feel to
raise a daughter in a world where you
can either be preserved yeah you can
either preserve her innocence or you can
step away and let her do the only thing
how about respect feminine great
question and there's two there's two
truths there's two truths that I feel
like I can hold at the same time one is
I would be very uncomfortable if any
female relative was or person that I
loved was exploring that profession like
I would have you can't even say it I'm
trying to be as as like professional as
I can yeah
no no no I don't think that I'd fail I
would have complex feelings to navigate
yeah on a higher level I don't think
that there's anything inherently wrong
with that profession and I respect
people who do it in a way that's
fulfilling to them and that brings them
happiness if someone's doing that job
and it doesn't bring them Joy obviously
I would not but most of the women you
have to understand it's not bringing
value or happiness
he's trying not to wrap it all into one
bundle because there's there's going to
be exceptions I think you just want to
be careful of like putting a negative
label over like so many people's lives I
think it should be negative though so
that young daughters don't run to her
and why don't we respect how you respect
them enough the femininity of them
versus respect for sex work
men should take birth control
huh
I think should be a choice
yeah well male birth control like does
exist the problem is there hasn't been a
lot of funding into making it like
commercially available you know it's
about you know making it an equal
responsibility all around especially if
there's a more effective way like a pill
um they can't just whine about the like
the side effects when they know that it
can significantly like decrease a
woman's quality of life when she's
dealing with all this so chance of
fertility her chances of I've never been
on birth control and I I don't believe
in taking it I don't believe in putting
anything like that alters my body I'm
not saying either party should have it
because personally I don't think that
anyone should put that stuff in their
body but if one's gonna do it and then
the other one should have the option of
doing it yeah if we're in a world where
women have the access to it and men have
the access to it should is just such a
strong word make the choice for your own
body that's why I didn't want forward
but yeah if you both have the option if
men had the right to birth control then
they would ultimately be coinciding and
deciding if a child should come come to
life right now women ultimately have
that decision no matter what you say she
gets to decide if she goes through with
it or not and I think that's kind of
problematic for many reasons but yeah it
goes back to like the why I stepped
forward with the military draft everyone
needs to take responsibility for
people's sexual and reproductive Health
but are you saying that because you know
that women would want a guy to take
birth control like that's more of like
like you want to please the feminists
please myself because I'm a feminist
that's what I'm saying I'm saying like
male feminists have a tendency to have
the talking points and they're like
women want us to take the birth control
so I guess we will but like do you
actually think that you would why
wouldn't I I why don't you get a
vasectomy I did did you I happened
okay yes
I decided to get a vasectomy because I
wanted to play a small very small part
in having men take more responsibility
for their sexual and reproductive health
and once I learned more about
vasectomies and the procedures it seemed
like a no-brainer for me to get it I've
known for a few years that I didn't want
children and so I'd been thinking about
getting a vasectomy and then Roe v Wade
got overruled and I just looked into it
and I started doing my research on it
and free of insurance yeah I was going
to change no side effects it's an
outpatient procedure so you go in 20
minutes you're out you go I went to work
the next day you should not take it if
you have any inkling of a doubt okay
about not wanting biological children
because it's not 100 reversible in some
cases they do it yeah right it's
Preposterous to me that it's only about
five to six percent of men in the U.S
have a vasectomy because definitely more
than five percent to six percent of men
in the US don't want to have children
that's true yeah because it's like
condoms
vasectomy there there is no like there's
no middle ground between the two right
and I think it's because of
patriarchy I know you hate me using that
word but like I think it's because we
prioritize them that's why listen we
have advanced so much you don't think
they could come up with a pill at this
point think about they've come up with
one just it's just commercial there's
not a market for it
I know centrism is like a okay I want to
hear from the disagrios
one thing that I do agree with is the
fact that birth control has a lot of
side effects and if I'm not going to
take that and a lot of people aren't
going to take that and have the side
effects then I don't think men should
have to either I think we live in an
over sexualized Society where we're
trying to yes find ways to solve this
issue because you cannot stop everybody
from doing it why not preserve and
protect yourself and not go around and
sleep with everybody but that is very
very fine small group of people that
believe that mostly in the faith-based
right communities but as far as you're
right to be able to do that and make
that decision and right you know totally
I just don't think it's ever going to
get I don't think it should be like
imposed on everybody type of a thing I'm
not for male birth control by force if
somebody wants to take that yes but I
think there needs to be more
comprehensive research and stuff female
birth control is a little sketchy at
times because there have been incidences
where they've had to recall stuff
because
I think one of them was like the old
Jazz they had
something like blood clots or something
yeah that's very nice birth control
and I hope we get to a place where we're
not using things where hormone because
other things a lot of people don't get
blood tests to check their hormones on a
regular basis and actually technically
birth control female birth control is an
oral steroid yeah so that's what it is
it's actually a 19 Nor and like people
are taking steroids I think we're going
to find out decades from now how harmful
this actually is probably for both sexes
and like and like unfortunately like the
pharmaceutical industry is so based on
profit that like if they think men
aren't going to take male birth control
they're not going to put in the research
they're not going to create it they're
not going to invest in it so if we
socialize and say hey like this is a
responsibility men should also have then
we can get Research into all birth
control to make it safer and more
effective for everyone so that we don't
ever not everyone has to be like
experiencing these horrible side effects
being a mother is the most valuable
thing a woman can do
you are a mother I am almost I mean I am
yeah here but she'll be born later
um when you choose to have a kid you're
putting aside what not necessarily what
you want to do in the future because I
believe that women have every
opportunity to still pursue what they
want to do even becoming a mother it's
very fulfilling in a sense to be that
selfless to to bring a human being into
the world and give everything to them
and watch them grow up and become their
own person and to feel that love
unconditionally that something
materialistic will never give you yeah I
honestly don't remember my life before
my son and it really makes me sad today
that more women 10 years more women in
the United States will be opting out of
marriage out of children
I that just is insane to me it's
innately in us to nurture and to
um to love and to care and to create
life we literally give birth it's a
ability a gift and it's also too much as
given much is required it's a massive
responsibility to raise the child
knowing that as someone said earlier
your children are going to be the future
of our planet
foreign
I think it's going to be the most
valuable thing that I do in life to uh
have children and create a family it's
just such a subjective thing and there's
so many things that people contribute to
the world and for I think most women
when they leave this earth sitting on
the deathbed they probably will think
the most powerful and valuable thing
they've ever done is to create children
you know there's like the famous quote
the greatest two things that you can
leave on this earth when you die is Art
and children and I think a lot of people
are going to feel that way I just don't
want to subscribe value to somebody who
doesn't see that as yeah or somebody who
can't have kids or Just chooses not to
right you know there's there's other
ways to achieve greatness but being a
mom is a great thing I I think we all
being a good mom
yes there's a lot of people who are moms
everybody's a good mom I was raised by a
single mom on top of that I was also
adopted so my birth mother had to make
an incredibly difficult choice to decide
not to pursue having raising this child
and then my mother who is a single mom
raised me and raised my siblings the
thing is is she was also like a teacher
and a professor and a principal and an
administrator honestly what feminism
really should be about and and is about
is making it so that women if they
choose to be a mother and just do that
for their entire life they get as much
respect and value and everything that
they should be afforded as someone who
decides to be a billionaire CEO as a
woman the feminist movement is teaching
women that it's the worst thing you
could possibly do because you're gonna
lose your money and you're gonna I mean
I think sometimes I think sometimes some
people listen in Echo Chambers and that
might be a problem but like also here's
the other thing are women not having
children because it's economically
difficult because in America we like
it's really hard to have the kids really
expensive we don't have health care we
don't you're fine but not for everyone I
know but I'm saying like that you know
what act of having a kid takes two
people yes but me and my girlfriend we
could probably afford a kid but we like
right now it's probably not good because
when you're making that decision but
here's the other thing not everybody has
that decision to make and it's actually
economically really hard to have a kid
in this country somebody's gonna have to
stop working somebody's gonna have to
make less money there's not health care
when I had my son I had no means I had
been trafficked obviously I made the
decision to see it as life and to have
the child and I had the child I had no I
was homeless in Newport Beach eight
years ago when my son was just still
nursing 10 months old worked around the
clock and didn't stop until he was
almost five years old until I got my
degree well if I try to handle child
care and they they the county pays for
it that's why I'm trying to say we do
have resources I was a full-time student
and because of each like that's that's
not everywhere California
will see Which counties California is
one of the more exceptional so I do
think there's resources if you look for
them and I don't think that just saying
oh it's expensive to have a kid like woe
is me I can't have a kid because I'm too
poor no we live in a country where here
like I said earlier we have the
opportunities to pursue what we can and
what we want to do and I don't think the
feminist movement has any place to tell
someone that they're too dumb or too
poor to be able to have a kid oh
absolutely not but that is what the
feminist movement is doing I agree yeah
maybe it's not as cool or or fashionable
to become a parent maybe like that's not
um what people are valuing feminism to
me and I think to to the other guys here
is is just like viewing the Sexes
equally and feeling like they should
have equal opportunity I don't think it
expands much beyond that no one here is
saying it's not cool to be a mom or
women shouldn't aspire to be a mom if
that's going to be fulfilling to them if
that's like your path by all means I
think you should do it my life was very
uh very specific and like direct with me
when we started dating she's like I want
to have kids this is important to me are
you on board or not and that was
something that was a goal that we set
for ourselves but she's not just a mom
you know there's other things she has
other Ambitions and she can do both of
those things that I think we all feel
that that's possible so when I hear you
say you know like feminism is saying
that like moms can't do this or don't be
a mom I'm not sharing that experience
we don't shame motherhood like our side
we promote it a lot of the times but
whenever you hear the opposite thing
it's usually from the feminists
men need to be masculine to keep their
families safe
of course he's going to step forward
look at him
I think there's a reason why people love
Andrew Tate and whatever you think about
him in regards to what he's being
accused of what she has not been proven
but that's neither here nor there men
gravitated toward that why because he
spoke to men in a sense of being a man
being a protector and you have to be in
charge of all your faculties and think
more critically so those aspects of
masculinity appealed to men because men
want to innately protect if I go on a
date and you take me out on a date and
we're go he's like no I wouldn't but
that's okay and you take me to a dinner
and you don't sit facing the door I'm
never going out on another date with you
it's not like we're helpless like I
can't do anything but having a man stand
by you protect you and your family and
your children masculinity is very
important there are situations like for
example like like 230 pounds my
girlfriend's like 110 five foot two like
there's no way if somebody breaks in a
house that uh she's gonna fight them off
unless she has a gun on her or something
but um so in that situation I would
the fill that masculine role but like
anybody can be strong anyway like in a
situation where I'm not there I would
hope if we had kids she could protect
them and defend them like the best she
could where I get the issue with like oh
men need to be masculine it's like oh
men need to always go uh go work and
bring the money and all this stuff
because my girlfriend she's Highly
Educated she actually makes way more
money than I do like way more I work as
a personal trainer I don't make as much
as she does it is traditionally not a
very masculine for a woman to make more
money than a man and I know some people
they will uh be like oh you're not a
real man if you're a woman makes more
money than you that's pathetic why is
she with you you sound like a loser
things like that and I don't let that
Define my masculinity I used to be
insecure about it but now I've grown
more mature and I feel like we're
getting a side where that's less of a
problem and like some people might
disagree with this and like but it's
just my opinion I think uh to raise a
son it's easier if you're a man it
doesn't have to be a follower it could
be an uncle or some positive real world
model same thing with a positive feel
long because like I don't know it's like
to be like a female going through
puberty but I was I was a young man
right now a lot of our young men are
misguided a lot of them are making bad
decisions and it's because like a lot of
these young men get this testosterone
boost their brains aren't fully
developing they like the vast majority
of crimes are committed by 16 to 23 year
olds
the reason I walk forward is is about
exactly what you just said men have
these feelings and this aggression often
deep inside them and it's about using
that aggression or those feelings that
you have to protect rather than to
inflict
I guess I'm just not entirely sure what
like just masculinity in general has to
do with keeping people safe could I
quickly respond and that I just think
it's that men have that natural
propensity towards it if I think of
rules in society that are protectors we
could say a police officers anybody
who's going to take on that role of
physical aggression in order to stop a
bad situation from happening men tend to
take those roles and and if you just
look at the the demographics of those
roles in particular men choose to take
that on and they persevere and drive for
it let's say
um I get married to a guy and he wants
to be a stay-at-home dad that's fine I
enjoy working so I actually wouldn't be
totally opposed to me grabbing the gun
if an intruder came in and being the one
to kill somebody if my husband's
normally like the one protecting the
kids I guess I don't think it
necessarily matters who's protecting the
family just somebody must I like what
you said about intuition though like my
wife has a lot of intuition I think
she's better than me like helping us
avoid avoid unsafe situations but to
physically combat a stranger that's at
your door with a gun a mask on and is
breaking in yeah it's convenient to have
someone who's more like him but would
you send your wife to use her intuitive
powers to handle that to protect or
would you use your masculine I'm not my
kid is my daughter's protected I'm going
down if we get attacked I'm going to do
everything I can to protect my family
that's not men having to be masculine I
just think that's people protecting
those they love I think when women are
put in situations where they have to
protect their families they can exert
tremendous Force obviously they're more
vulnerable because they're not typically
like as strong on average testosterone
right I just don't I don't think like
this is something men have to do I I
think you gotta be careful about putting
pressure on men to embody some sort of
like Macho tough
I've had men in my life uh who like
embody that tough role and it it like
creates uncomfortable environments it
sometimes invites aggression danger to
the situation it's a certain
role-playing that I think Men actually
it's beneficial to grow out of why do
you think it's a role though what if
that's just who they are it's innately
in them so then I think they should go
to therapy and work on it and get out
that aggression so I understand
regression isn't bad I always hear from
other male feminists like oh that guy's
trying to be a macho guy why absolutely
so here's the thing I think sometimes
it's not genuine he's playing a
character actually I'm usually the one
to de-escalate situations because of how
I look and how I'm presented so I
de-escalate and actually I always tell
people I don't and I always encourage
young men avoid the fight yeah if you
can avoid it stay away but if you have
to obviously do what you have to do like
survive and I would say to women or
anything but Dylan's heart and actually
try to deter get away because violence
should be always the last word
only brings more violence
the differences between men and women
should be celebrated
foreign
I'm talking about poles of energy we
have polarity in everything in the
universe from the battery you can't put
two negatives and into a battery and at
work you can't put two positives has to
go flop so there's polls day and night
everything yin yang it's it's energy and
every we are energy I don't think
everything's polar though it is why why
apply one lens well you just step
forward with the prompt that said that
masculine men and women's differences
that you can celebrate I want to
celebrate the difference between men and
women but I feel like you're doing
you're this you have this tendency to
apply sometimes like these Quantum or
because it is because we live in a
Quantum Universe
I think he's just saying to celebrate
differences doesn't mean we exist on two
opposite poles
that I'm saying that so I'm saying that
there's things exist in nature that are
our triangles or Triads like not
everything's yin and yang you know but
but it kind of is I actually believe
that the masculine energy energy
is a little bit is elevated in a sense
that they have more responsibility as
protector provider and so for women we
like lean to them and we look up to them
as the leader so not to say that they're
not equal but there's a little bit more
responsibility in the masculine field
and without those outlines of structure
then we have chaos and we don't have a
society we have no more children because
women aren't having children anymore I
don't think I fear chaos as much as you
I just I you threw in a little nugget I
have to take it you do see women as as
not I don't I don't see them as the same
levels I just read it I would encourage
you like from a loving place to just
maybe challenge that like how might your
experience
I think women are four quarters a guy is
a dollar I think they're equal and
they're just not the same yeah I think
that the The Prompt and what I really
took to is that it's so important for
you guys to celebrate your femininity
and celebrate what it means to be a
woman for you and we will joyfully
celebrate that with you right and
likewise to us however we want to
express our masculinity that should be
celebrated right in whichever way you
had to do it and like you know like I
said I don't think it's as rigid as like
we want Society well like some people
want us to think it is but it should be
celebrated because there are innate
differences that are like just
biological and there's going to be those
differences and you know there shouldn't
be anything frowning problem like uh you
know women being like more softer or
emotional it shouldn't be something
frown upon but if a man chooses to be
that that should be like that's feminine
that's not masculine that's you know we
should celebrate those qualities and
people can the disagree step forward men
are more enslaved than ever before
oh
this is a tough one huh I agree with
most of what everyone said it's just the
should I agree that the differences
between men and women can be celebrated
and I celebrate it I think most people
do to some extent um
do as you please yeah I feel like it's
important to celebrate it because I know
for me part of with gender dysphoria I
would really enjoyed you know emulating
and having masculine traits and being a
man so being able to celebrate that and
say all right fantastic I can celebrate
that this is a different thing than what
my sex assigned at Birth wouldn't tend
to go for but celebrating both sides of
those things and the dichotomy that may
be different is really essential to
allowing anyone to really just Express
themselves the way they want to thank
you guys you guys are all amazing thank
you very good sports yeah I wish we
could do it yeah
yeah you guys is all very helpful got to
see another side of feminism
[Music]